each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
follows I hope you had a very pleasant
pleasant dinner last night and a good
rest today we have a very busy day we
have four tracks in the morning
concurrent tracks you're in one of them
and this afternoon we have planar ease
as well and we have a surprise for the
social event tonight as well okay now it
is my pleasure to introduce dr. Judith
bishop she is the director of the
computer science theme within microsoft
research connections and she will be the
first presenter of this session and then
she will be chairing the whole track the
software engineering track so please
join me welcoming dr. Judith bishop
Thank You hermie and I've delighted to
be here in Mexico it's my first time in
Mexico and I have found it absolutely
wonderful I've visited all the great
places on this side of the country of
course there many great places on the
other side I've still got a visit so
what I want to talk to you today is a
bad software engineering and the title
of the talk came from a survey that came
up just about a month ago where they
said software engineering was the best
job in 2012 so this was a pause one
survey among many surveys but I think
it's very encouraging for us in computer
science to find out that this kind of
thing happens because it means we can at
least tell prospective students and so
on that this is a job that you could go
into however let's look at the reasons
that they used in order to decide this
of course they were not technical
reasons there were reasons related to
job satisfaction and so forth
you know how much money you earn whether
you can have a low level of stress I
assume that means a low level of stress
not a high level of stress and whether
the work environment was very good
clearly in the picture which accompanied
this article that the work environment
was pretty cool similar to here so I
think that this was a good starting
point for a talk but clearly in my talk
I'm going to be somewhat more technical
I want to start off with a little bit of
history about some large efforts in
software engineering that you'd be
familiar with many people are not really
familiar with the Microsoft ecosystem
they might be more familiar with what's
gone on in other blodge ecosystems over
the last ten years and two of them are
Eclipse and Java that came up through
other big companies and big communities
I was very much involved in the java
community myself when I was a professor
and it was very interesting how things
went so people used to work in those
communities and they had ways of getting
together and integrating their code
however in Microsoft we have a slightly
different way of doing things in
particular one of the things in
Microsoft connections which is the part
of microsoft research that I work with
is we do want to collaborate with
universities so we have various ways of
collaborating and here's a whole list of
them all so why do we do that why is it
important to collaborate with
universities I'm often asked myself this
question and part of it is that we're a
small organization Microsoft Research
well small in terms of the bigger
picture large in terms of any other
research organization where over a
thousand people now
but if we collaborate we get to be
10,000 and that's fantastic then you can
imagine what we would be able to do in
terms of projects and so forth and it
keeps us on track because we have people
verifying what we're doing amplifying
what we're doing and of course we then
can catch and support the leaders of
tomorrow and that's a great thing that
we do one of the people here today is
Harold javed he's a very important
person to talk to because he runs our
programs for the faculty fellows and so
on and there's a picture of the latest
ones that have just come out there are
some amazing numbers of our
collaborations that have gone on these
are some of the recent numbers we've had
more than 25,000 scientists come to
events and more than a thousand interns
come every year to Microsoft to work on
our projects so those are young people
who come and work on the software
engineering that we do and I'm going to
highlight one of the projects from one
of my interns in what I say upcoming
also we have conferences that we sponsor
and that's part of my portfolio and so
if you're interested in that kind of
thing do come and talk to me about it we
can't sponsor every conference that's
around but we do tend to also sponsor
conferences in regions and that's a big
thing so finally before I get on to the
whole software engineering this is what
I do in my theme so we have different
themes as Tony pointed out yesterday we
have five of them at the moment and the
computer science theme spans areas that
are applicable to the people in our
theme and we currently have software
engineering semantic computing mobile
computing we had a wonderfully
comprehensive talk by Victor ball
yesterday about mobile computing and
also parallel ISM and concurrency and
this year we've got a big summer
school in Russia on that unfortunately
it's not available to people who don't
speak Russian so you can't sign up for
that programming languages and of course
the community interaction that I've been
telling you a bit about so why do we
want to actually look at this whole
software engineering thing from the
point of view of collaboration these are
some recent spider diagrams and if you
can't really see the words on it don't
worry I'm going to blow it up in the
next slide but this was work that came
out of the National Science not another
Academy of Science in the US and what it
highlighted was that between the period
of 1996 and 2011 collaboration between
countries has increased dramatically so
in other words scientists are
collaborating more and more and more now
if you're going to be collaborating as
Tony pointed out in his keynote address
yesterday you need ways of assisting
that collaboration so software has to
underpin it and I'm going to discuss
some of that but let's look at these
figures a little bit more to see why we
need it it's very interesting that in
1996 the USA so what are these figures
was producing the majority of papers
that were in the major conferences pople
pldi oopsla and PP OPP and from the
other countries shown there which were
Germany Canada the UK and so on there
were some papers but the lines show you
that the papers went co-authored fast
forward and let's fast forward to 2011
and the picture changes completely the
u.s. is of course still the biggest will
they have the most money and the most
people working in the area
so that's fine but what's happened is
that all these other countries are now
interacting and collaborating both with
the US and between themselves so what a
line indicates is that there was a paper
at one of these major conferences for
which there were authors that were in
the same paper from different countries
fantastic okay so I think that given
that we need software engineering tools
to underpin and under to support all of
this kind of collaboration just to show
why Microsoft is very very keen on this
as well microsoft research is very
highly ranked in the top CS research
organizations there is another talk I
hope it's not on at the same time but if
you can go through it and don't want to
attend the session it's later on maybe
or tomorrow about Microsoft academic
search and this is Microsoft academic
search and it's showing that the top
computer science organizations include
Microsoft IBM AT&T labs and Google so
it's not just universities that are
pushing in the research effort one more
of these in software engineering so
their software engineering there
Microsoft is in fact top so it's the
work that we do in our lab really is
something extraordinary I cannot show
you all of it i'm going to show you just
a few things that will be I hope nice to
take home and these are them so this is
the talk I want to give you an example
of software engineering in the large
you've already seen some of those in the
keynote this is one more then software
in the browser software in the social
experience and my earlier slides led up
to that because I'll saying that if
you're going to collaborate with other
people and across countries and so on
you end up having to have a social
experience
Rian's which is a little bit more than
coming to a nice conference you need
real underpinning social aspects in the
large and then finally software
development kits so let's get going the
challenge this is the challenge that
Microsoft has had for a long time we
ship software EG windows to billions of
computers in the world we wish more
people would actually pay for that your
stuff but actually it exists in billions
of pieces what we want to do is make
sure that any bugs that are there are
reported back to us and fixed in the
minimum amount of time because then we
can get that bug fix art to everybody
it's very likely that if you've got a
problem somebody else among the billions
have got the same problem so we can all
share the fixes how does that happen
within Microsoft so this is how it
happens a crash occurs on your computer
oh dear that's not fun you get what's
called a mini dump so your computer
automatically takes a dump of the state
of the computer it then asks you whether
you will allow that many dump to be sent
to Microsoft that's really funny that a
lot of people say no I'd like to
encourage you right at this minute to
say yes because the information that
gets sent is going to help in the bug
fixing and if it isn't sent the bugs
aren't going to get fixed as easily so
do say yes next time you get this little
pop-up then what happens is the
information goes out to a big server and
a whole section of servers and then this
is the the the cool part there's a
program or an engine called analyze and
it does a hash coding of the
many dumped and it hash codes it into a
whole load of different buckets now if
you look at these buckets at the bottom
you'll see that the one on the right
ended up with 23 million many dumps oh
dear that is obviously a very popular
bug the one on the Left ended up with
only five so that's an obscure bug so
you could see where this is heading we
are going to then work out and send our
bug fixes to the most popular bug so
that we get the most people satisfied
the most quickly so this engine has been
working for 10 years now it's called
were windows error reporting and it has
a about 500 different heuristics in that
hash coding algorithm and they're more
getting added each each week as the team
decides okay there's another kind of
error that they're starting to find they
need to fix that then what happens is
that you get these kinds of interesting
graphs just to show you how amazingly
well this works this was in ms word last
year when we brought out in his word it
was tested out on the company's
employees first we tend to do that it's
called dog food and the company's
employees tested this program a
Microsoft Word and there were 9,000 of
them and in the first three weeks they
found that the 20 buckets accounted for
fifty percent of all the errors so that
was that analyzed engine working away
very fast and the bugs going to the
right people to get fixed as fast as
they could and to get sent back and into
your code as fixes
so we try very hard and to get all these
bugs fixed we fixed 5,000 bugs in
Windows Vista you might say they were
probably still more vanoza first it
wasn't all that popular but there were
antivirus vendors who said they'd like
to buy this software from microsoft and
they did so in fact the software also
runs in other companies occurred as well
and the office 22 team managed to fix
about twenty-two percent of all their
reports that they received in three
weeks he has two more graphs and then
we'll finish with a section this was an
interesting one hardware bug so once
again as Tony said yesterday not all the
bugs that Microsoft gave gets or
Microsoft bugs but they come to us
because they're part of the operating
system ecosystem and this was one where
there was a hardware error in certain
chips but it was showing up as a Windows
bug so we were able to track it and as
you can see it took about nine days
prior to when the bug was fixed which is
the blue line there and then there were
very few reports after that and those
would clearly those machines which had
not received the fix of course if the
manufacturer had had the software he
could have they could have fixed it
themselves as well lastly
this kind of software also can be used
with malware in other words intentional
bad code that is inserted into systems
and this was a real problem that
occurred sometime in 2007 where there
was a bug which was inserted into
Windows code and as you can see the
reports went up in the millions we had
over a million reports coming in on the
same thing so that meant it could get
far it could easily get found and then
as you can see the bug fix went down
straightaway and this goes out globally
so there is a paper about this it's
earlier on in the slide so when you get
the slides of the website you'll be able
to go in and read the paper and see more
of the details exactly how analyze works
and so on and of course it is a
commercial product now as well and it's
a very valuable thing for microsoft
itself so that's how microsoft research
works with the product teams to solve
some of these big problems another thing
we've been doing in our group is working
with universities to try and see what
are the kinds of software they really
want and I want to give you two examples
the first one obviously is programming
languages now universities are always
thinking about new programming languages
and how do we change our programming
language move on to the next best thing
it's always a bit of a headache to do
that because these days students have
lots of different types of computers
they don't just have Microsoft computers
they might have linux or mac operating
systems and it's necessary to kind of
accommodate that so one of the ways that
one can do that is to have the software
initially anyway
running in a browser so if we look at
this stack here in at the bottom one can
say all right well we're going to go for
a particular integrated development
environment and everybody must choose
which one they want let's say the whole
department switches over to eclipse or
the whole department switches over to
visual studio that's not really that
flexible so moving up a little bit one
could say well let's not worry about
which development environment we use but
let's standardize on the language well
that's also a good way to go and most
people go that way another way you can
do it is in fact to say well we're not
going to worry too much about all of
that and what we're going to do is teach
principles and so on and we'll access
everything through a browser and i'm
going to show you actually through demos
how this works let's look at two
examples there two ways of doing this
browser based software the first way is
that you have a sandbox approach so the
sandbox approach is where you access the
browser and the software comes through
the browser onto your computer and runs
within the browser as a as a piece of
software there it's a control that comes
in all the computation is done here on
the client so it's quite fast and there
is no additional hardware needed you you
don't have to be online after you've
already got it it's it's fine the server
approach is somewhat different so you're
going to get one of each here is where
you maintain a server presence all the
computation is done on the server and
clearly the advantage there is that the
people who are running this kind of
software can look at the usability and
that's a big advantage the disadvantage
but that it might not scale however we
haven't found that to be a problem the
servers that we're running in redmond
for these kinds of systems and you saw
one of them yesterday which was Daphne
don't seem to have a scalability problem
at the moment so both of these systems
have advantages this is the first one or
an example of the first kind a language
called F sharp is a functional
programming language which is used by
many people out there and it's used
particularly for financial applications
for large data applications for
accessing programs in the cloud and so
on it's also very good as a teaching
language for initial functional
programming so with that in mind we
developed this browser-based capability
which is shown here so in the middle of
the browser you'll see that there are
some programs on the left hand side
there's a tutorial and on the right hand
side is the apps output from that
program that's running in the middle
I'll do you a quick demo of that and of
course there will be a demo on Friday
where you can come and talk to me about
it so the software engineering aspects
of this are that it is built inside a
system called Silverlight it's a control
in there it's built on a particular
stack the whole thing comes down into
your computer it's about just over a
megabyte at the moment it's not very big
and it also is deployed at the end of
the day up into windows azure up into
the cloud and the whole thing wraps up
into the public internet so let me show
you actual example of this working if we
can switch to this machine while they're
switching the machines i'm just going to
carry on with us slides as soon as that
comes on will do the lemma all right
it's fine
so this is the other kind of software
this is a different one altogether this
one is called picks for fun now the
originator of pécs for fun is possibly
in the audience Nikolai are there he is
right right in the front so pecs for fun
is a system which is a simplified
version of pécs where pecs is a unit
tester which runs on top of net it can
be launched in various ways but one of
the more exciting ways is to launch it
through the browser so it's one of the
type to that I showed you and you can
access it and you can run it and pecks
for fun enables people to write programs
and then have them unit tested
automatically so that's quite an
interesting aspect of software
engineering because unit testing is very
very important a technique to learn and
to try out however why it's called for
fun is that this unit testing has been
turned into a game by the pics for fun
system and the game is whether or not
you pass the unit test so let's look at
it this is what the screen looks like at
the top you've got a little program up
there and the program is meant to do
something when you say ask pics which is
over on the left what comes out is a
list of inputs and a list of outputs and
then whether or not the outputs conform
to what the program should have produced
and then you will get error messages so
one of the error messages over here was
index was outside the bounds of the
array and the other one was a hidden bug
which you have to somehow get around so
as you can see there's Nikolai's name
and this is a technical report you can
get online which has more about pics
which hopefully we will be able to show
you so pics works by dynamic symbolic
execution and there it is
there's a program and it takes the
inputs it observes what is the
constraints and execute the programs for
each of the inputs that can generate now
there are just far too many inputs for
anybody like yourself or a student or
whatever to test all of these but a
computer can do it so it solves them and
it produces the observed constraints
that keeps going and eventually it will
come up with a numerous types of
constraints which are going to be valid
or invalid and then there's no path a
left at the end of the day so it can
then systematically work out what are
going to be the different types of
inputs and outputs and whether or not
the program that you've inputted God's
validates those so pecs uses the cloud
extensively everything is compiled and
analyzed up in the cloud so I like this
because it looks a bit like the see the
results are shown in the browser but the
browser is not anything other than
something which is used at the end one
of the nice features about the latest
versions of pics is that when you're
writing programs it does also use auto
completion so you have there's a pretty
fancy editor in there for writing
programs you don't not just writing text
you're getting a lot of help what is
auto completion you can see there when
you're starting to write console dot
something it gives you a menu of what
might be applicable and as soon as you
type a w it'll give you the options that
might be applicable and as you continue
along it'll tell you what is available
now why is that useful because you might
not think that most of your students
Java and Java is not one of the
languages that picks will fund supports
pics will fund supports c-sharp video
basic and f shop which is one of the
languages I told you about before so you
can use this without knowing too much
about C sharp and learn a lot about unit
testing that aspect of putting all the
programs up in the cloud and having them
run so that you can use them is then
generalized in by the same team
Nikolai's team in this rise for fun
program now we didn't hear very much
about rice yesterday so I just want to
iterate that rise for funds stands for
research in software engineering and
it's a big group of over-40 researchers
at Microsoft Research who all work in
software engineering and these
researchers continually produce tools
and they're collected on this website
called rise for fun you can go in there
choose one of the tools that has
something to do with something you're
interested in and just run it if you're
on the internet you could do that right
now and each of the tools has different
levels of tutorials different levels of
explanations and some of them are
extremely interesting just what you
you're after now I said that with this
whole collaborative software engineering
thing you'd really do need some kind of
social experience so one of the ways
that most people get their social
experience is on facebook and of course
a try f sharp has got a facebook site
peckville finance got a facebook site as
well so facebook is one of the places
where we now go and place our tools and
ensure that the community gets to talk
together pics for fun however has taken
this to a greater level of social
experience
they felt that since there was this
gaming aspect of trying to match whether
you were hitting the program that was
underlying there this could be turned
into a game and so they have coding
duels so now you can see that there's
this little exam logo up there called
coding duels and when you have solved
one of these coding duels you then get
points and marks and so on and so
there's a leaderboard so it's actually
fun and engaging one of the interesting
things about this is you cannot cheat so
there's no copying of code from somebody
else or anything you are playing against
the computer the computer knows what the
correct answer is and you have to hit
that correct answer with the code that
you devised and then there is a game
board this is the online board which we
could show you if we had this up but it
doesn't matter which we could show you
and continuously minute by minute
throughout the day if you go to pixel
fun and go to this online feed you'll
see that people are playing when they
get the little cross swords it means
they've wanted one a duel that means
they've solved the problem so it's a
great community there there's a
leaderboard it says thousands and
thousands of problems have been solved
in fact I think we're over 700,000
Nikolai 900,000 have been solved now and
so people are using this from all over
the world it's a great place to go and
engage in order to improve your
programming skills but remember my talks
not about programming it's about the
software engineering that's supporting a
social experience for worldwide stuff so
I would have given you a demo but don't
worry about it you can get the demo over
at the demo fest on
no you can't peckville phone is not
being shown we'll see if we can still
get there lastly social aspects in the
large this is work which was done by an
intern last year so one of the biggest
code bases in Microsoft is Bing Bing is
our search engine and it has over
1,000,000 change sets or branches of
code that's a lot right so each of those
can can contain over 200,000 check-ins
and 700 branches 6 million different
files look at the numbers I mean these
things are just out of scale that you
would have imagined right it's almost
impossible to crawl this thing
incrementally so the techniques that
Tony was explaining about branch
analysis yesterday almost fall over when
you're doing this kind of thing so what
happened was that researchers at the
University of Washington invented this
new way of doing things by using
probabilities they said that they could
predict whether or not a particular
branch was going to be checked in or not
checked in at a certain time they won a
prize for that paper last September and
the intern who was helping them work on
it came to work for us and we got him to
work on this Bing code so it's called
speculative analysis and it predicts
what users might do in certain
circumstances and then we they can store
the results and if the user does choose
to do it we present the pre-calculated
information that we worked out at the
beginning if the user doesn't choose to
do it it doesn't matter we were just
using spare computer cycles to work out
all this stuff anyway but the
information doesn't need to be saved I
mean doesn't need to be used it's just
saved in case you need it yeah
Oh work we've got that okay I think
we've got one more right so they're two
more on this and then we can do the demo
so this is the same kind of diagram that
Tony showed you where people are
checking out branches of code and then
if you see they started checking things
out on about the tenth of the month and
on the twenty-fourth two weeks later
they fund they've got a conflict well
that's a problem if they could have
found that conflict earlier or found out
that they would have had a conflict
things would have been a lot more
efficient so with this system we can do
that sorry let's go back you can see
that red arrow over there with our
system it warns you it doesn't actually
do anything it just wants the people
through a social engineering aspect on
visual studio through a plug-in that
there might be a problem and this is
hard works done here in this bottom
section it works out and it notifies the
particular user through the pictures of
the people that are working on the
problem and says you know you might have
problems with your files with these
people who are also working on the same
file down the road so it's a predictive
warning analysis system based on all
that code very very clever hopefully it
will be a release soon and it will be
actually available it's currently being
better tested within the Bing group so
all right we want to do our demo let's
do that quickly are you all ready
it doesn't matter if it doesn't work
it's okay don't worry about it we've
actually got enough to talk about all
right mm-hm so the the last thing that
is relevant here is software development
kits so not everything runs in a browser
I'm sure you've already realized that
after all browsers are limited so we do
need to have some more robust type of
software which is available more
generally to people and in my group
we've got quite a lot of this going on
in fact we've spearheaded several
software development kits the one is
called Project Hawaii and this is for
doing mobile computing in the cloud and
Victor ball told you about that
yesterday so they are services which you
could get on your phone and they can be
executed in the cloud like optical
character recognition speech to text and
so on and those are available in terms
of a library which they've written in
which we promote just to mention one fig
there is that a project to ye is also an
outreach program and we learn phones to
people all around the world so if you
would like to use that but you don't
have windows phones in your particular
University you can write to us and we
can set you up with a phone loan program
so that's quite fun talk to me
afterwards the other one is connect now
obviously connectors Peter Lee said is
one of our huge success stories and
following on from the launch of connect
there was also the launch of a software
development kit where you could
yourselves through a library of routines
make things on top of connect and that
software development kit is also
available and it's available to
academics it's now available more widely
as well and you can get that finally
there's something called web and graham
and within graham
a way of getting content and modeling
types available through the web so I'm
going to end up now by showing you a
couple of slides on this we've talked
about large programs large programs or
things that we mind but large data is
also something that we bind and this is
a large amount of data taken from bing
and if you look on the left there you'll
see that if we access that data in a
cloud and count how many times various
words are used you'll see that you get a
certain type of cloud so the word data
there was used a lot more than others
and inventory and release and so on but
what's more useful sometimes really I
don't think it's necessary yeah just
leave it I'm going to be fine no problem
so that if we collect some of these
words together depending on how the data
has been accessed recently what we get
more is these kinds of clouds the one on
the right so release inventory data is
in fact what we really wanted because
that was the kind of information that
was stored there rather than just the
individual words what's very important
these days is linked data data which is
linked up in various domains so these
are all websites and data curation sites
which are available under publications
online activities music over their
geography cross-domain life sciences how
does one make sense or even access all
of this data so two things one is that
we do something called a concept search
so when you search for data you can
search by means of some or other concept
and that comes in and looks at whether
you're searching not just for the
texture word but via
a certain context so you can see we're
searching for the word company and it'll
give us a whole lot of companies Google
IBM Microsoft etc Cisco but if we search
for the word company in terms of what
does the word company mean then it says
legal entity organization and so on or
it could talk about types of world
famous companies massive companies
big-name vendors and so on and lastly we
can also do this and this is through
bing now these days you can find whether
you want to find out film's budget you
can actually get tables coming out and
there's an enormous amount of work going
on in the back of being to produce this
kind of table through those linked data
set ups so it's getting the semantics of
the data in advance working out what it
is that you wanted through the film's
budget it's not just coming back with a
Wikipedia thing that says films and
budget understanding what it was that
you really really wanted and comes back
with a table of that sort now how do do
I in my group try and help you to be the
next group of people who are going to do
this work with us which we would love
well we've got these seif awards and as
you can see we've got quite a few that
have come out of the time and we would
like to have more we give 25,000 US
dollars that's a seed funding and not
only that but there is an invitation
usually each year starting this year to
come to a safe day where you meet the
Microsoft researchers work with them for
they discuss future projects and so on
in software engineering we also go out
to conferences to the major conferences
such as exceed we have a workshop called
topi and the next one is coming up in
two weeks time in
Switzerland where we discuss special
issues related to this kind of work that
I've been describing so in conclusion
I'd like to say that software
engineering from my point of view is
really analytic these days it's not just
a process that we go through which it
was when I learned how to do it long ago
it's now something where you've got to
analyze data understand data and work
through the next steps dealing with that
huge data it's also technology transfer
thoughts from the point of view of
companies it's no good just putting out
systems there and saying you're going to
like this you're going to love it use
our systems we need to work with you and
find out what it is that really works
and I think try F sharp which will be my
demo on Friday is one of those where we
really try to understand how if shop
might be something that academics might
or might not use and so that was a win
and then finally the social media
aspects young people of today really
make use of social media in a huge way
and in fact all people do as well you
can find peterlee on facebook and very
soon you're going to be able to find
tourney hey on facebook we hope and the
social media is a way of understanding
the way that other people work it's a
way of connecting up and ensuring that
we can get feedback and handle forums
and of course special social media such
as the ones built into pecs for fun
exceptionally good so I'd like to leave
there and perhaps there will be one
question while the next speaker gets
hooked up thank you
Thank You Judith any questions okay here
the mic ok
I I've been teaching computer science
all my all my life and I wonder if we
have an advice for how do you prepare a
professional so that he or she can be in
this in this new world of doing software
engineering wow that's a great question
because I was faced with it for many
years myself I think I did two things
that may be of use to you the first one
is I tried not to be dogmatic about any
type of software so that was I said to
the students that if you're going to be
a professional out there don't say i
only use linux don't say i only use
microsoft keep your eyes open keep your
skills adaptable all the time make sure
you can put everything on your computers
keep yourself fresh read what's coming
up make sure you are up to speed on
everything that's the one thing the
second thing is to try as far as
possible in the university context which
is not always easy to put bigger
projects in front of students sometimes
it's possible to link up with local
local companies and that's the greatest
thing you can do because they tend then
to get a flavor of what's going on there
is time time for more questions while
the next speaker is getting ready
no more questions who is the next
speaker Nikolai okay so thank thank you
very much Judy okay